all right you got your list of addresses
right here
okay all you got to do is go up to each
house and throw the newspaper at their
front door
got it i'm going back to bed thank you
georgie you've been a wonderful teacher
and i'm very appreciative
steve took the time hi my hands are
black
why are my hands black relax it's just
the ink from the papers
why wasn't i warned of this
oh damn spot that's from shakespeare
[Applause]
[Music]
take it easy
[Applause]
[Music]
hello billy are you our new paperboy yes
i'm joining the workaday world
i work too i take care of our chickens
don't get the wrong idea when i grow up
i plan on being a theoretical physicist
cool i'm sticking with chickens alrighty
then have a nice day
you too oh cool it's monday
[Music]
how's he doing and out here 20 minutes
this is his second house
he throws like you
[Music]
to say this first day was challenging
would be an understatement
to say the rest of the week got better
from there would be the kind of lie that
says pants on fire
take it easy
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
fun fact the larger sunday paper
required a second bundle
go gear
after a week of tangling with animals
mother nature and a delivery man with a
good arm and a bad attitude
it was time to reap the benefits of my
hard work
collecting collecting
hey sheldon hello mrs sparks i'm here to
collect for this week's paper delivery
right hang on also i'm given to
understand that tipping is customary
so feel free to express your
appreciation
here we go
you tipped me a dime is there a problem
no which just doesn't seem like very
much you were late
every day well i had to breathe the
elements i saw you
brave isn't the word that i would use
hey sheldon you look sad i
am want nick
[Music]
foreign